i need a game i need a game to put on
the machine look at that there's just a
menu screen back there with my basic ass
it looks like it looks like you know
command console or dos gotta be mine it
is it's a menu system
this is what you get today guys
[ __ ] three
three guys one one of them trying to
figure out his audio
i think
would um like to hear what you sound
like when i talk that this is the new
sound of troy baker
he's so he's so versatile i can hear you
now by the way you you sound like the uh
text transcriptions on tick tock videos
hi
this is your closed captioning we would
like to let you know that you have one
i love it
let's see if you can maintain that the
entire hour
i can i can maintain it for four hours
yeah union rules yeah i was going to say
wait a second someone give me
give me a goddamn game reach back i want
one here from mike bethel i wanna hear
from mike bizzle reach back i don't give
a [ __ ] what console what year does it
matter let's see if we got it let's spin
the wheel
of emulators and see what we got
because i got up here too
not and not enough time to do to do that
mm-hmm
there's a lot of writing on this mic for
you spotify i just want to just send a
shout out right now i just want to send
a message of love to all of our spotify
listeners if you're on i heart radio or
apple i guess we don't care about you
because we only talk about the sponsors
guys you sound like you're getting ready
to tee up and add uh an ad reader but
yeah here's an ad read for you we don't
do ads um
that's why we made a very consistent
viewership what did you see this recent
um did you see the recent uh
the family guy bit of like peter as a
podcaster where he's you know oh yes i
just wanna talk about hatch
no it's it's uh the hatch that i know
it's because it's all ad reads it's like
lois is on the phone we gotta call her
and she's like please they're holding me
to jail and he's like oh well that's
gonna be useful because where you have
pillows if you do a special discount
code or whatever and then it ends with
zip recruiter he's like zip recruiter we
wildly overestimate how many of our
listeners are in a position to hire
people
i was like that's true i have heard ads
for that specific company i think on
every podcast i've ever listened to well
it like south park did that you know
sponsored uh sponsored content um
episode once and what's the funniest we
didn't realize that that's always
happened i love that uh i love that
minority report movie you've ever seen
this the one with the tom cruises
he's a good one i've seen a couple of
his movies
uh
that that right there was like like
walking past and they could track and
and
real-time
ads
yeah we are oh god
damn i gotta watch that movie tonight
it's so good here's the problem though
follow us guys we're bouncing around um
are we gonna talk about midnight mass
can we talk about midnight mass i watch
about it i i'm i'm the admin talk about
it unless you unless you've seen it i
know i might have to kick you out mike
because i watched the whole thing and i
was up
episode two and so far i'm like i was
right like episode and not like in a uh
um oh i guessed it i was like is this
where they're going with this and
episode two is just like
maybe
so
it is delicious it is delicious
it's funny a friend of mine was texting
me earlier saying i really hate
not well i don't know if she said hate
but she said i'm not into jump scary
horror should i watch it and i said
honestly i wouldn't describe it like
that i said it has those moments you
know throughout it has those occasional
but
i remember while angela and i were
watching it we finished i think it was
the end of episode three when she said i
don't think i've ever watched something
this slow paced that has held my
attention this well that's what everyone
said to me everyone has said to me it's
slow but but excellent but this is like
true horror like go back and watch
rosemary's baby yeah it's definitely not
it's a sleeper until it's a weird party
yeah i i the way i described it was
it feels like this archer who's really
slowly
pulling it back and taking aim where you
know as soon as they let go
you know it's like a fire arrow that's
gonna hit and explode and sure enough
that is what happens like the show it's
it's just so to use that analogy though
here's what's interesting i have a
friend of mine that's that's like a
really accomplished archer and he says
the goal is not to be able to hold that
the goal is to be able to look
and see and rapidly pull it's like
hawkeye like hawkeye being able to pull
it from his quiver i i don't know for
you guys i don't mean to suggest
but to me that's what the show does as
well so your your analogy of being able
to i think you're wrong i [ __ ] you not i
wish you could see this
hold on
i have no idea what happened brother i
wish that i could talk to you right now
but you are not gonna believe this [ __ ]
first of all just say hello is that
rahul hey hello
hey there he is so if we have to cut
this out are we going to first of all
are you in distress are you in any kind
of emergency
yeah it's not live but i [ __ ] you not
it's as if
were your ears ringing because we're
literally talking about i i can't talk
about you right now because i'm only
watching episode two and i'm
i might leave my wife for you
[Laughter]
my god that's perfect that was the i
could not have planned that any better
he pulls back
pull his back where were we he pulls
back the bow
and he just so it that that's what the
show does it's like there's there's an
archer in the woods and he's watching
for some prey or
game or catch whatever the [ __ ] they're
supposed to call him and then also he
goes crack and just
nails it that's that's to me what the
show does so it's not that like it's
it's this long
it's it's there's no tension
and the absence of that tension to me is
what adds to the mystere
or the the mystique or rather of of the
show
but here's here's where your boy got a
little judgmental i i was looking at
some of the performances going
i don't know how i feel about this and
then i went
my bad
my apologies i i i want to
rescind what i was thinking and now i
get what they are doing and holy [ __ ] so
i'm high
my you want to have like a spoiler chat
and i'll pull the headphone out and just
let you guys roll for a bit or you're
not far in it troy you said no yeah
i'm watching west wing for the first
time for [ __ ] sake like i i'm not the
guy that jumps on the bandwagon i still
haven't seen what if and a lot of it is
because
my wife is is borderline neck or left no
no narp elect what's the one where you
fall asleep
narcoleptic necrolysis necrophilia
um so anyway that's it it's hard to get
her to sit and watch for 45 minutes
because at the end of the day she's like
this looks fan
so that's my life
um
but yeah that was me and i were watching
the expanse it broke my heart
wait so you were you were the stay awake
and she's the fall asleep
she's not normally but that show sadly
uh the expanse specifically did that to
her but no we were we were on on um we
had a
um
uh
night
on midnight mass that was just like when
we when last of us two came out where
we were like you know one in the morning
going
we can't in good conscience stop now
we're so close to the end and so just
just decided it's just gonna be one of
those
it's just gonna be one of those nights
and so plowed until like past 2 a.m in
order to finish i've missed my 30s
i'm barely in mine anymore but
uh no i paid for it the next day uh yeah
but uh 6 a.m comes early doesn't it yeah
yeah it was it was it was it was a
stone's throw away by the time the alarm
went off but it was
it was worth it but i i don't i disagree
with your analogy though uh or your
revision of my analogy because the whole
point is that specifically
the potential energy of watching
somebody pull it back imagine imagine
it's your hawkeye but it's you're
watching it in slow motion the point is
that it looks so deliberate and
calculated the whole time you think
i'm sure they're aiming at something i'm
sure i'm not quite exactly sure what the
target is hit the target for me 100
awesome yeah
i mean again just just two episodes in
so uh again this is not giving anything
away but the my favorite scene so far
is the uh rec room scene um where there
it's just the two of them sitting and
having a conversation
that to me
hit every box like
this is not in any way a supplication to
mike flanagan but
there's
there's a director that told me it was
like performances are great but i can do
far more with the scene with the camera
than i can with dialogue and it's the
old adage of alfred hitchcock saying the
same thing is like when all else fails
use dialogue
um dialogue should be your last resort
and there is so much that this show does
absent of any dialogue and it's just so
incredibly powerful it's it's the
um i i equate it a lot to in music i
thought that everybody needed to have
those mutt laying wall guitars you know
that that phil spector just massive
amounts of sound hitting you
and
it's actually if you really want
something to sound big it's taking it
away it's very same in in game design so
many features that are added in i really
like a simple hud i don't want i'm i'm
really loving going back and playing
uh length awakening right now i'm almost
done i'm
two more away from from being finished
but just the simplicity of design
that lends to now the enemies have to be
harder and it's more about
we can't do a lot with mechanics
it's four directions that's all you can
do
but the
and the enemies are always going to be
scalable to whatever weapon or whatever
abilities that you have but it's now
just about mazes and it's about
figuring out how to apply this with this
and being creative that to me is is
brilliant
to that point if i may i had a question
a little bit more directed towards you
mike there was a point in this game
where even the people that if you're
playing links awakening on switch
there is a uh
it's just a it reminds me of that scene
in fight club where the very beginning
edward norton is talking about his job
and his job is to go around the country
and investigate uh
car crashes right yeah car clark car
crashes and falls specifically with cars
and he says that if the payout is less
than the cost of a recall they don't do
one
so
that right there does not sound like a
false premise that sounds to me like
uh
chuck palahniuk knew something that
nobody else did
and it was like this is the truth and
what would happen it just kind of spun
off from that little acorn of a thought
but there
nintendo knew that there was this
problem where if you did not go in in
certain order and get the keys and
unlock doors in a certain way it was
potential for you to be trapped in this
dungeon
and that's it you can't you have to go
back and start the game all over again
have you ever found yourself in or or
austin do you know of a game that that
is similar to that twerk i literally and
i've been kudos to whoever did this walk
through because they've really been
helping me out tremendously because i
want to enjoy the experience of the game
and i don't have the com the amount of
hours needed to organically play through
all this so yeah i'm a cheater whatever
[ __ ] you um but
go ahead and kick you out of the stream
right now yeah
the power too
um but the
do you know have you ever been in a
situation where like guys here's the
situation we can undo this entire level
we can undo we can rewind the clock with
design or we can just let the player
experience it
that's not a bug that's i'm talking
about like a a like a chord that like
the player can work themselves into a
corner that yeah yeah that's i would
argue that that's the biggest kind of
fundamental shift in game design
thinking of the last like decade or so
is
it's no longer fashionable to do that
and it's interesting when you see
something like dark souls which kind of
goes against that grain but most i mean
play testing arguably one of the core
reasons to play test is to find those
moments either literal in terms of like
actually like you can get to this point
and get stuck because you've not got
something or like just on like a
theoretical level of players always get
stuck in this fight and
you know 30 of our players can't get
past level 4.
modern game design sees that as a
problem and and fixes it basically
that's kind of and i've definitely been
in those situations where we've realized
oh god we've got like this level is just
too difficult or or you can get to this
level as you say without an item and
that's a problem and you ultimately
normally the the kind of the general
wisdom is you fix that and you kind of
change that but what's interesting is
now you're seeing the kind of rebellion
against that from game designers and
from game players with games like dark
souls where where we're kind of
embracing the fail a little bit which is
something that hasn't been the norm for
a decade basically like at least
um you know when you look at something
like
i guess probably the most famous up
front was valve right with half-life i
feel like half-life was the first time a
game developer really talks about play
testing and like we we put this in front
of users and we work out where we want
to put things
in terms of like a public facing kind of
sure but you're talking less than 20
years so that this is
yeah
yeah this is this was this is
and you see that as well with like i
remember sounds of time a large part of
the conversation around sounds of time
was that was considered one of the first
games to do a lot of like level uh level
direction or directionality with
lighting so you know they put a light
above the stuff that we all take for
granted now a light above a platform
that says you need to go to that
platform yeah the classic kind of
naughty dog which color is the ledge
going to be in this franchise it's
usually it's yellow there but well
uncharted it's white right it's bird
[ __ ] and uncharted it's yellow in
last of us it's
you know but that that kind of thing
that's my point of like that kind of
design thinking of we're going to either
subconsciously or consciously kind of
guide the player to where the fun is is
kind of a modern game design thinking
when you when you think about a game
from the eras you're talking about like
things awakening or whatever
those games were designed arguably with
like the opposite intent which was keep
kids away from the endings so they get
the values they keep dying so they keep
repeat playing i'd say the error of
things awakening it's we're going away
from that but like that was definitely
the arcade mentality in the early
console
we're now in that loop back towards like
dark souls games that actively like i
said embrace the fail and and and that's
interesting because that's a bit of
language that games have that other
mediums don't have if a film stops
halfway through and goes actually this
film got kind of crap you're not allowed
to watch it anymore
that you know that wouldn't work in a
film but in a game we can actually play
with failure we can tell you where you
went wrong we can all you know encourage
you to try again there's lots of
language that games have that other
mediums simply don't have
so what do you attribute the change like
what what brought you you mentioned
half-life but i mean what what really
said
i i feel like the advent of metacritic
is kind of like the oj moment for video
games
yeah it's [ __ ] i i believe
yeah absolutely
only in los angeles but we just love to
riot if our team loses we right if the
team wins we riot um no i i
i i i can't um for the spotify listeners
he tried to mimic the same movement by
uj simpson with the glove
if you don't know what i'm talking about
go to 1995. um i
i remember like
that that's why i said o.g sims is one
of the most influential people of the
20th century because
he forever that moment where he
haphazardly
changed the way that we view news the
way that news operates the quote news
um a sudden
it has to be the most generous read of
that moment in history
right like
i feel like i feel with with murderous
intent he changed history actually i
actually think that that's the perfect
word because even if he was found guilty
the extra layer of covering it like a
reality show that wasn't his choice
that's true that was an unforeseen
outfit that was yeah that was yeah there
wasn't any design in that that was like
oops but like from that we also get the
kardashians from the kardashians we get
the rise of the social media star from
that
reality tv generally
donald trump the network's realizing
yeah
procedural tv happening so it was like
this huge one they said that the most
influential um invention in modern
history besides the wheel and like
gardening and [ __ ] was the light bulb
because it had such an impact there was
a huge boom
because people or sorry there was a
there was a decline in human population
when the light bulb was invented because
people could stay awake longer so they
didn't go to bed so they didn't bang
that's crazy the light bulb
single-handedly changed the way that we
functioned as human beings that's really
interesting so i think that metacritic
all of a sudden when you can quantify
what people think about your game to me
change the way that we design our games
because what you're saying is it was
keep people there's this they get a
little frustrated fine we'll put out a
magazine every month and maybe we talk
about their game and they can get a
couple of hints because that's what we
got before right we got we got that what
was the nintendo magazine that came out
power it's into power that would come
out every month and it was like oh by
the way we're talking about this game
now did you know there's a secret
dungeon and if you get a key you don't
get it you you [ __ ] yourself you know
that kind of thing but i think that
metacritic changed the way that we
both view games and the way the games
are made is that true or false
i don't know i i think mexican might be
another outcome i would say it's more
the kind of popularization of games and
crucially i think as well and this might
be a reach so apologies come with me on
this journey i might talk myself out of
it
it might also be a result of the
audience aging up right because if you
look at like the last 20 years what's
what's the defining thing about games in
the last 20 years they're now 40 year
olds oh sorry so
genuinely last of us is also to me an
indicator of like wow there's a there's
a large portion of the audience who
wants to hear a story let me let me
check out what neil's written on this
piece of paper about fatherhood and you
know what i mean like it's like there's
definitely like i mean
that's a meme that's obvious that like
loads of games are playing with those
kind of ideas so maybe that's it maybe i
think what happened was when you were a
kid
oh god dude god damn it mike bithell fix
your router fix your router mike
look at that highly intellectual pose
though
yeah he's he's basically like the
thinker
yeah solving all the mysteries of modern
game design and the internet goes no you
don't watch this
for all you audio listeners
i'm i'm trying to be better man look at
me
i think the lack of mic all of a sudden
is fairly clear probably most clear to
the audio listeners yeah you played a
game for five hours straight you you got
stuck you talked down the playground
with all your friends who were also
playing the game you you know pirated
stuff onto discs you did whatever like
it was a communal activity among the
kids on your street or in your school
as we aged gaming became a part of your
evening and you had a relationship you
had a family you had a job you had all
of these things and maybe the player's
patience for
uh being punished by a game went down
and our expectation that a game would
get to the good bit
went up i don't know
i've been cut out of the call
i don't know if i was intentional austin
if it was i love you for it
here's what i love when zoom does it
goes okay we're going to compress
everything he said
i don't see it i'll still
one of the nerdy classical music
instagram things that i share had like
uh oh he dropped fully they had the um
they had the um you know like chopin
over zoom edition where it's the piece
and then there's like three bars of rest
and then
i laughed so hard when i saw that i was
like that's definitely like a music dad
joke but but um delicious well here
without mike here to
interject i will offer if you think i
will i think that for my
uh
taste
the um
the
simultaneous rise of social media is as
or more important as
metacritic because
i think player feedback
is ultimately what is driving this move
toward games that are not as punishing
towards
having some sense of guard rails on and
realizing that you know the the goal
with exceptions like dark souls or or
even like bloodborne or demon souls or
any of those guys yeah or like a lot of
a lot of indie like super meat boy or
celeste things that go out of their way
to be challenging um
uh here he is
uh they they they they i feel like those
are increasingly fringe
and and that's ultimately why troy is
responsible for the
that was perfect wait where did i get
how long had i been talking before i got
cut off was i i don't know we weren't
really listening
we had you muted and we were having our
own conversation we did the likes
where the video of us listening was
looping for you have i interrupted
austin
austin's midpoint i'm very interested
because i already want to interrupt him
well basically mike i was saying that i
it seems to me
that social media as just a conduit for
player feedback to the developers and
publishers
is it seemingly as
or more important as metacritic in
helping to
expose to developers this general
desire for
less punishing less kind of brutal
gameplay because before you had other
than getting angry letters through snail
mail which is about you know one
thousandth of a percent of players that
would actually go to those lengths or
like calling the tech support line on
the back of the box or whatever
your ability to even know
how it's going
it was severely time lagged and you know
and and nowhere near as sort of
representative sampling you're only
going to get the most sort of
like busybody type
players that need to have their voice
heard and i feel like now also talking
to each other right more than developers
like you can you can tell the internet
game sucks as quickly as possible now
right yeah i mean i guess there were
like chat rooms and stuff you know it's
not that long ago but like how did you
get player feedback
before
you know honestly i feel like probably
it was useless to you anyway because by
that point you've printed the discs so
yes we're talking about like update
culture like you're not you're not
updating a game post release unless
unless you are on the tier of like
half-life where you're releasing like
additional add-on content or game of the
year that's what game of the year
editions used to be game of the year
editions used to be a way of doing those
patches because so i i think of like
orange box being the first kind of real
dlc situation right
well no no like you've got like if
you've got the old um the old gearbox
stuff for half-life like you've got
that's what i think is that no the
original half-life like oh not half-life
2. no like opposing force and uh blue
shift and those are all i got you i got
you i didn't realize those were
downloadable i definitely have an
opposing phone sorry no no i was on disc
you're absolutely right that was on a
disc apologies you're saying dlc you're
saying yeah i remember talking about
like
you're saying
pass that kind of whole thing that
that's like within the last
never mind season pass just downloading
to begin i'll never forget when i went
to install
or something with half-life when it was
like we need you to install this thing
called steam in order to to and i'm
never thinking about angry
i was like i don't want some [ __ ]
program on i just want the game i
remember i remember i remember seeing
stephen
i saw steam at e3 i was like losers
fly by night i was like these guys are
going to go nowhere
i remember doing the exact same thing
with fortnite i remember i remember
seeing four nightmares like that i
remember the trailer i was in the
trailer the first it was me and fred
tata short for the first trailer for
fortnight i was like this is gonna be a
cute little game little indie game they
showed it at e3 and me and fred were
going huh and that cute oh that was
gonna be the largest game ever okay cool
ever
uh
yeah i don't know i can't prognosticate
to save my life groundhog day looks at
me just like [ __ ] idiot
i i i guess to me it's
this feeds into a much larger
conversation as far as like
at what point do you shut off the noise
at what point do you go i need that
player feedback you and i know mike how
you feel about any feedback is good
feedback um and it's
it's incumbent upon you as the developer
to be able to go i'm either going to
throw that away or somehow apply it if
it's actionable i'm going to listen to a
little bit more if you just your game
sucks okay that's still quantifiable
data that i can somehow apply
and and be used
um
at some point though you are making a
mike bithell game and i'm not saying
that because it's a mike bithell game
it's bithell games
is with you at the head is making a
certain type of game that you believe is
the game that that is a studio should
make for right now
but if at what point you go okay we have
to turn off the player feedback
at some point we can't listen to this
you have to yeah well so so there are
definitely likes i mean fortnite's a
good example right of a game that is
completely different from what was
originally intended because yeah paying
attention to player feedback and that's
i'm not saying that's a bad thing like
that's an approach and then clearly has
worked really well for them
for for me because i'm more of the kind
of pretentious in the end of the
spectrum for me where the line is is
um
i take on the feedback that helps me
achieve the game i want to make or my
team wants to make as well as possible
and that's it if a piece of feedback
gets me to a better implementation of
the game and this is where play testing
is really important and then good play
testing
companies and good play testing teams
will ask you this is
essentially like what's the filter here
like what do you what what feedback is
useful to you and for us it's always we
want this game to be xyz and i've done
this i've written for play testing teams
like my vision of what this game is like
i think this game is about this and it
empowers players to do that and this is
what this is the best version like this
is this is me talking up like my dream
this is what i want the best review of
the game to read like right and i'll lay
all that out and then you hand that to
the play testing team and if they're
good what they'll do is they won't just
tell you all players don't like this or
players do like that or players got
stuck here they'll tell you all the
places where you're not achieving what's
in that description of the game and
they'll help you to kind of figure out
how to get closer to that you're never
gonna get the dream perfect game but
like how you get close to that for me
that's that's the thing is and this is
true of feedback across the board is the
more specific you are with the question
the better the more useful the answer
you're gonna get and you can't get that
from social media when people are just
telling you oh your game sucks that's
not super useful that's not going to
guide you towards a solution it's the
same as if i'm
if i'm getting ready for like a wedding
and i turn to kerry and i say how do i
look i can get a million different
pieces of feedback some of them
actionable some of them not because
they're related to the takeaway i had
for the last five years right tall
and tall exactly
thank you carrie um i love i love how
posh we were in that that's great um but
like there's
quite tall um
but if i say to like how's my hair
looking then i can actually work on the
hair and fix that you know what i mean
and it's i think that yes
what do you think it's like
f i can't do [ __ ] all with you you're
[ __ ] though i can change
and that's the that's where for me the
line is but that's one approach and i
would never present that as like the
only approach because yes you can do
what fortnite did and go we're not even
we're not paying attention necessarily
we're not just paying attention to what
people like about our game we're paying
attention to what people like about all
games so you know this battle royale
thing seems to be kicking off so we're
gonna bring that in like that's a level
of awareness and it's a very back that
goes beyond that yeah and you need like
millions of dollars to do it as well
which is another aspect of that go ahead
arson i want to ask you a question too i
would think that the majority of
play tester feedback that developers
would be getting would be a lot more
like what you were describing for your
games just because
most games
you know
if if if naughty dog is getting feedback
from testers complaining about the lack
of battle royale options in the last
episode
they're yeah it's like well you know i
guess you're just not our customer
that's you know like what else can you
do beyond that but if the does if if you
know if neil gives the and i'm sure he
does the same stuff i do in terms of
giving the notes to the play test if
he's given the notes to a play tester
for some reason that you know i think
last of us is actually like has to be
the quintessential perfect multiplayer
game
and he's making last of us and the play
testers load up and it's not that then
they should give that feedback that our
audience actually wants that so it's
it's about what are you going for what
are you trying to achieve how do you
best achieve what you're trying to
achieve is to me that's the the best
filter for play test data specifically
like dude this is the kind of thing that
i wish sorry troy
this is the kind of thing that i wish
you know when you're in high school or
growing up or even in university
and you're in these writing classes
there's always this it's kind of like
studying for the test as opposed to
studying to gain the knowledge and to
see how the world works where a lot of
these writing classes are about
this artificial sense of how to
essentially sound smart
and
the epiphany that you invariably only
have long after you're actually in those
classes is it was never about that it
was about
maximum accuracy so that whatever point
i'm trying to make is not getting lost
in the translation translation of my
brain to my hands or my brain to my
mouth that that there's the least amount
of friction there as possible i've
always i've always it took it took a
long time to really kind of i feel like
understand that it you know the use of
certain words so-called you know fancy
words or whatever sometimes
these are pretentious and pointless and
other times it's really because there's
such specific connotations that that's
exactly what you're trying to say and
the whole point is to make your
intentions clear and because it's
communication ultimately right nothing
no great human achievement happened
without one person successfully
communicating an idea to another person
from like well
you know that was quite good actually
that's a quote let's put that on the
[ __ ] t-shirt please if it's not a
quote i mean i remember it's now a quote
there's a good example i probably stole
it from somewhere someone communicated
it well to me and i passed it on
there was a great moment of
feedback i remember on journey the the
the snowy mountain uh towards the end
the way that level is sort of mapped out
is it's kind of like a big corkscrew
where the exit
to the actual like summit of the
mountain for the end of the game
is directly above the the sort of tunnel
you walk out of and you don't really
you're not really aware of it it's just
that as periodically as you come around
corners you're kind of reframing the top
of the mountain and seeing oh there it
is but what it is is you're kind of
making your way in a sort of corkscrew
pattern more or less and the funny thing
was that
in the initial designs it was
fairly hardcore because at the top as
anyone who played it might remember
there's like violent lightning and wind
and stuff and there was this thing where
the wind could blow you back and so in
the earlier thing it actually had the
chance to blow you all the way back to
the beginning
of the level because you're you're
you're right there at the precipice of
it like it took it took just the tiniest
push to set you back and and that was
one of those things i don't remember if
that made it to the point of external
player feedback or it was just an
internal team thing of going this is now
where
it's now telling the player that it's a
different game than it is like we want
them to feel the punishment of the wind
but not to the point of them going
[ __ ] all i just spent 15 minutes through
what is the most kind of arduous part of
this whole game and it and it just in
the snap of a finger undid all my
progress there's another type of game
right where that would be the perfect
design right for sure that's what that's
why i get really frustrated there's a
lot of like especially and i hate to i'm
not going to pick on anyone in
particular but like youtube design
videos i get served a lot of those now
because i've like what do you mean what
are these i'm not going to criticize
anyone there are there's like
i would say like very you know good
couch designers right on youtube
who will point to stuff and go this
mechanic
uh sorry this design this level design
is the best possible way to design a
level and that's so out of keeping with
the nuance and beauty of this shot of
this entire field is that what you just
described with austin yeah is a terrible
choice for that game
but for that kind of game it would be
the defining moment that we'd all be
talking about for years to come right
like and that's that's the beauty of
working in a creative medium is there is
no right answer you're just trying to
get towards the best version of your
answer at all times and it's kind of a
so
carlos santana is
um
considered by most to be like one of the
greatest guitarists
even rolling stone in their top 100
guitars of all time listed carlos
santana the top 20 i'm sure at least
carlos santana from a technical
standpoint is not great
he doesn't do anything like
far better than me too you but you you
put them up against like ingva momstein
or somebody or or uh steve vi or any of
those guys that are known to be
shredders which technically what they
can do with their fingers is just not
human
and carlos antenna is like that's not
what i do man
but what makes carlos santana such an
incredible
guitarist is
anything that carlos santana plays
you could play mike i could play
you instantly know that's carlos santana
i was looking and the real genius is
that
you can do that too
whatever austin's great technically but
like from a creative standpoint i don't
know if this is the right form for
established conversation i don't think
he's great
this is an intervention this isn't that
this is look on troy's face of objects
we will get to his like all right let me
let me tell you what i think you mr mike
moneybags [ __ ] whatever there's no
pepsi this is a bear who do you think
you are that's not tea that's whiskey um
but to me it's it's the it's not just
the ability like anybody can look an
observing critique that is far easier
than to create from nothing sure this
idea so
there's even stuff like um
man so
there's things that people have adapted
and looked at and have done a
re-envisioning of it and the person who
created the original thing is like yeah
it's a better version of that that's
but i did it first you know it it's not
not being in any way bragging or
boastful but it's just simply like but
you didn't come up with that first
anybody that sits there and as you say
you know kind of sideline monday morning
quarterbacks and goes i should have done
that better i bet every designer
animator actor composer
writer everyone goes yeah [ __ ] that's a
better version
but you didn't stare at that blank white
page in a blinking cursor you didn't
look at that
blank screen with no code on it you
didn't look at that score sheet or
whatever with no notes written on it and
write the first thing that to me is the
true not talent but true skill because
talent is worthless talent is worth it
is just inherent and it is nothing
without being actually utilized
talent doesn't exist i don't think it
even exists i think talent is an
interest in something basically
maybe a proclivity towards it like i
watched a three-year-old am i
well i don't think you're born with it i
think it's just something that you if
you love something or you're interested
in it you just spend those 10 000 hours
without thinking and then you're like oh
wow i'm this amazingly talented xyz but
actually it's because you worked it even
if you didn't know you were working on
it because you loved it you don't think
there's any kind of pre
disposition to certain basic
intelligence
you know i really don't think i agree
with this i love it here we go mom and
dad are fighting
so
i think
the
example that i would use is
someone like jacob collier
um if you're familiar with him he's this
you know
like
youtube generation
bedroom
uh you know
like singer artist producer he's won
multiple grammys now
um he
he
is
if there's any musician i've ever come
across that you could righteously say is
the 21st century mozart it's probably
him he is the most he's how old is this
guy
12 20 probably he's young
um and there's no doubt that he works
hard and does a lot but he also
he hears music on a level
that
most people will never even appreciate
never mind that even if you explain it
to them he has this he won a grammy for
his uh rendition of moon river that's
like a hundred layers of him singing
and at one point
he
to create maximum resonance he breaks
through and modulates to the key of g
half sharp major
meaning
it's not a key that you can duplicate on
a piano for example he he he found that
the resonance 50 cents in between yeah
and it's perfectly internally in tune
and it's intentionally in that space and
he has a whole long video where he walks
through
what he's doing for most for a lot of
people what he what he's doing is it's
almost off-putting because it just it's
like information overload and it's
really clear that this comes
very naturally to him now i'm not saying
that
the wunderkind sort of you know like
kind of like a cousin of the auteur
mythology like i'm not saying that
he is
devoid of effort but like as someone who
has an appreciation for
musical abilities i can i can i can
humble myself when i look at a guy like
that and go he can do things
that given my entire rest of my life i
will never be able to do
have you ever secretly plotted
to murder him
tell your name
have you ever is this a salieri story in
the making uh it is oh my god
that got me good
i was like what does michael and say
have you ever secretly applauded like
plotted
no i i i i was a secret thanks i guess
the problem right is that that you'll
we'll never know because all of us just
live in one brain right like we can
never know what it is to to have the
brain of someone else and and and you
know what i'll experience i'll take it
yeah but like to that point like again
every saturday is traveler soccer day
and i'm watching this little my not my
son my son is a
weird proclivity towards athletics i
don't know what happened but he he's
just he's good at soccer specifically
but there's this other kid shay
who is just abnormally agile
plotted
[Applause]
[Laughter]
no i think
you know give me a guy messi or whatever
already he's like no you haven't well my
quit my question is
is che to use jay as an example like is
this kid i've never met is his last name
by the way
oh he might have a second career after
the football um
as a as a co-leader
really good musical it's not very good
um
the um
no he's my question is is with che is is
it that he was born talented or was it
that that kid just loved kicking a ball
so much that before he even goes to the
the youth thing with your with your kid
that like he's already got ten thousand
hours man it could be that that's the
that's that's my question i don't know
which comes first it's a chicken and egg
situation like does that kid
just love kicking a ball so much that
they just have done like when i think
about like my innate skills and the
things that i would consider to be my
talents they're all things i was
obsessed with as a kid so presumably
just put in hours of people on paper but
i've met people who are as
obsessed as i am with what i do for
example
who they i look at them as almost tragic
figures because they're not that good at
whatever they do and
i got contemporaries are the same way
i'm like you're really into acting
and uh you're not working more not
working you've studied
and you know more about like you could
you could quote stanislavski and all of
that you know everything
and i just think that there's something
somehow it doesn't the yeah the wires
don't connect that's interesting yeah
i'd not thought of it from that angle of
like what about yeah you're right the
the
massively
interested but crap person kind of may
disprove my argument that's interesting
not thought of that angle i think it's
an interesting i i think the biggest
takeaway my biggest agreement with you
would be
that
it is
it's clearly not a
you know uh
sweat equity
only but nor
innate
brilliance absent work you know because
we always i like i i think i've quoted
this on here before but when house of
cards first came out and was this big
hit the composer
um who had been a successful multi-emmy
winner he'd been in tv forever but
suddenly he was kind of the talk of the
town because the show was a big hit and
you know everybody you know the music
makes a big statement it's it's a big
you remember it when you watch the show
because it's a big part of the of the
narrative experience and and i was
talking to his wife and she said yeah
jeff is he's like a 20-year overnight
success because you know
everyone forgets that he's been in this
business since like the 80s um
and uh
so
that's that tends to always be the case
anytime somebody seemingly explodes in
from nowhere there's never
it's never that way there's always a
backstory but i don't think that that
invalidates
that some people are just naturally
you know naturally better at certain
things whether they're interested or not
yeah i don't think you're wrong mike i i
i think that it is it might be i'm kind
of coming around
coming around these are good arguments
youtube i just simply feel that yes
this might be the series finale of this
show
watch this watch this to
to the the point of what we were talking
about as far as design
there is that tipping point between to
to use that from a you know different
thought in a different book into this
argument there is a tipping point
between player frustration and player
success where you want to design a game
to where someone goes okay i did it i'll
keep going versus [ __ ] i rage quit
right ninja gaiden three i never
finished that game because the final or
not even the final boss battle just one
boss battle was just designed poorly it
was impossible to beat and it's not that
i would maybe it's not that i wasn't
that good it's just they did they didn't
design well enough to where you could go
back and get more health to be able to
to beat this and then it's another boss
after that it's like it impossible is
too hard maybe for someone else they
could do that for me i couldn't it was
enough for me it was at my threshold i
quit and never played the game again
but for somebody else it's like hey i'm
naturally adept at this like it's i
can't do that thing
perfect thing for me
athletics was just not a thing for me
sport was nothing but frustration and
failure and insecurity
but i could sit down at an instrument
and just naturally do it and then that
i've never had a piano lesson i've had
one drum lesson i had one bass lesson
and no guitar lessons and i just devoted
myself to it because i had a little bit
of proclivity to me a talent is not a
fire it is a spark and that spark can
either
vanish without a trace and without even
barely a puff of smoke but if you'd like
tom hankston in castaway if you plow at
it and continue to diligently mine it
then it can become something but that is
not talent that is skill and that is
learned over time so i i think that
there are certain people that have a
certain proclivity or or
matched with an affinity towards
something that leads to the development
of that skill i think that's probably
also those naturally correlate
it seems very
intuitive that they would naturally
correlate because if you because i had
the same relationship with sports you
know i played sports i tried a handful i
you know i went to
you know like a basketball camp and i
used to play ultimate frisbee with my
friends every friday for years but i
always preferred you know things like
mountain biking where it's it's not
the competitive structure is not there
it's i like being physical i just didn't
like you know
uh the vibe of of those because i was
never there i was always surrounded by
kids who were so much better at it than
me that it was like anything i could
hang on to to enjoy was was lost um
and um but i think that the correlation
does make sense that if you
your interests would naturally chase
that which you have a decent talent for
because there's a positive feedback loop
of yeah you you you don't need actually
actually makes the tragic figure more
impressive right right
that's someone who's
kept trying in spite of kind of those
limitations
i love robert evans like if you've ever
read which is a great book or watch uh
the kid stays in the picture bob evans
his
narrated by him
uh
self autobiography
he said i was a decent actor i was okay
but
his biggest thing that that started him
in this whole thing was he happened to
be at the right place at the right time
in the beverly hills hilton in the pool
where so many different other stories
have have what was the other one uh
austin you always talk about west side
story west side story it's what it was
sondheim and um
sondheim and bernstein and jerome
robbins and arthur lawrence i i it's a
short story but i was i was in the pool
i was at the
they have these little um kind of cabana
style lunch tables that around the pool
and i was uh having lunch there once
with john mao cherry who was bernstein's
personal assistant for like 18 years or
something and very very close with him
and we are having lunch
and he just goes by the way you see that
table over there that's the where the
brainstorm session happened where it
went from east side story to west side
story because they spent about 10 years
writing it and it early on it was called
eastside story anyway he was like that's
where they made that decision and i just
doesn't sound weird i'm just like i'm
such a sucker for that kind of thing
yeah and i wish i could remember what it
was that catalyzed
um but anyway finish so you're bob
so bob evans talks about how he just
happened to be the right place at the
right time and and
the the
wife of the producer i can't remember
who it was um somebody probably could be
screaming at me and telling me
um for the hemingway story the
bullfighter was going to turn it into a
movie and everybody he shows up on the
movie to play the titular role and and
he's the star and everybody on that
movie showed up and one even person i
can't remember the it wasn't eddie
albert but may have been
um
said a telegram saying
if that kid shows up on set i'm done
and he came in
and he
did the big scene that he was supposed
to do
and
everybody was prepared for the entire
cast to walk out on him
and he grabs he he grabs the the bull
horn and he goes cut that's it the kid
stays in the picture
and it was this one moment where he was
like i don't want to be here i want to
be that guy i want to be the guy that's
able to call the shots and so this thing
that he had been chasing for a long time
like he'd been an actor for a while
finally he was like oh so i do believe
that diligently trying to get that spark
if you're not
it's it's again it's the castaway moment
he had been trying to do this and he had
like you know hurt his hand and all of
that and he had just given up and it was
the air got to it there's always a
missing component between nailing what
it is that you want to do and actually
applying what you need to do in order to
accomplish the result so i don't i don't
necessarily consider them a tragic
figure unless they never get the heir to
it if they never figure that out for
themselves so they never go wait a
minute maybe it's not this that's why i
tell everybody it's like more than
anything i'm not i'm not an actor a
director a writer singer anything i'm a
storyteller so if for some reason nobody
decides to hire me ever again i'm not
crushed because it's like oh i don't get
to do that anymore i i it's one arm of
me telling my story now i do this and
that's why i think it's important to not
limit yourself to one specific thing
it's it's
generalize yourself and be able to i'm
going off on a soapbox i love it
to the point where the comments on this
i i think i think um yeah i think the
the moment for me where i realized
exactly what you're saying have kind of
took it to that next level of like well
maybe i want maybe i want to make it so
i don't have to wait for someone to hire
me to make the hell i want which is the
dream right like that or at least that
was my dream
um so yeah this makes me think of that
one
in a scene in a in a film full of
moments i love one of my favorite scenes
in rudy
is where uh his dad ned beatty
uh is that is that a biographical movie
about rudy giuliani dude you beat me to
it i had the restraint to not make a
rudy giuliani
i know there is one right no no no no
that's that's
sean aston the movie about the kid who
wants to play football for notre dame
university oh i'll stop i'll stop there
was one there was one starring oh what's
his name um definitely not from hercules
what's his name there is a rudy giuliano
biopic right that's like it's the guy
probably
what's the who who plays um hades in the
disney movie hercules
james woods james woods there's like a
james woods rudy giuliano giuliani
biopic i'm sh i unless i dream this i
might have dreamt that he dropped this i
think he may have yeah
like he wants it to happen well so
which is absolutely miles and miles away
from anything to do with rudy giuliani
it's the true story of daniel rudiger
and his goal to being part of the
notre dame
uh
football team and the whole thing is
that he's short
you know he's not a great athlete
but he's the biggest fan in the whole
universe and he won't take no for an
answer he's also not the best student he
can't really get in academically all and
his you know it comes from the super
working class
family of like factory worker types in
the you know the like i think it's like
you know
like pittsburgh area or something like
it's very
and um there's this great scene with ned
beatty as his dad sitting there on the
bench on the uh bus stop bench getting
ready to board the bus to head down
there not even sure if he can figure out
how to get in he just wants to go he's
just gonna go and like knock on the door
of the university and go can i come like
he has no concept for even the process
by which to apply or any of that
and he's saying you know there's this
great beautiful and again it makes me
think of the kind of tragic figure where
his father is saying
you know a school like that and his
father's also a huge fan they would
watch this together so it's coming from
a place of
it's almost like
my presence there would solely this
great thing because i know i don't
measure up and his dad says you know
a place like that is for great thinkers
and great athletes it's not for us but
don't get me wrong there's nothing wrong
with being a rudiger we can have a damn
nice life but that is for other people
and of course rudy is like you know
you're wrong i'm i i have to pursue this
and it's a great it's it's i just love
that it's one of the most heartwarming
it's pure optimism it is yeah
what else is heartwarming
the movie rudy which exists i've
manifested it check out chat i've just
sent it to you no way no don't tell me
this film may only exist because i
imagined it i may have some people
oh that's right you're right james woods
played oh that's no we talked about this
have we talked about this before no idea
was it no idea i've never seen this film
you're a fellow countryman
um
john uh oh my god
yeah
small island you guys know each other
yeah um
it is what else has this director done
robert dorn helm robert dorn help did
vienna blood you know that movie the
fish um he did the break
oh he did into the west ooh
that's why this guy's a dick you're
listening to three men scroll live
um
about 20 minutes ago to saying uh
i don't think i'm gonna be able to make
it this week so have fun so
less expectations
without her i want to interject uh
to our topic at the beginning uh
forgive my not to spending time on the
rudy giuliani movie i know that's what
everybody's here for but uh
current this is important my favorite
example of a brutal game design that
would cause pitchforks and torches today
if if
unless it was a super
fringy uh indie developer who's known
for this kind of thing and that's like
why people play it but it was one of the
most unforgiving
things that nowadays i i just laugh
because it's it's brilliant in its
boldness is in space quest two
when you're on the like prison ship and
uh all the cells open and a and a you
know
giger style xenomorph comes out of the
cell after you and your instinct you
know as a student of pop culture
as roger wilco space janitor you see the
xenomorph coming towards you most
players are going to think i should run
and so you run and you you survive and
you move on with the game
but if you if it caught you
it it would and you know sierra it's
worth mentioning sierra games were were
always like the antidote to lucasarts
where it they were you
on every screen was a thousand ways that
you could die and fail the game and and
invariably what happened to me all the
time was that i would i would save the
game not realizing i was seconds away
from death and then that saved game is
now a permanent loop every time you load
it you die immediately there's no way
out of it you just have to simply start
the game over again there's no auto save
there's no checkpoints and so i remember
on this one
video game design this xenomorph if it
catches you it picks you up and then
gives you a kiss and puts you down and
walks away and it's supposed to be one
of those like oh that's funny they
psyched me out la la la la then you play
the game and like hours later
suddenly your chest explodes and you
lose the game no uh and it lets you
it lets you go no indication nope
my mate i would think it was the best
thing ever in my memory that was like
the ending of the game you literally get
to the end and then you can't win
because of it but i think i'm
mythologizing in my i think it's not
quite that dramatic but you can
definitely make substantial progress
before you die and there's nothing you
can do other than just start the game
over amazing you you will hear me talk
about this a lot i'm sure i mentioned it
before but um if you haven't played
shadow of war uh i'm sure it's a part of
you know game pass or or whatever it's
it's
it's such a great game um and and to me
it is it's it's such a fun open world
game um
i'm really proud of that i'm glad that
you know i whatever
but one of the best things about that
game was something that they did um to
help immortalize one of their
senior
senior management vice president of the
company who who started the company and
ended up through the course of the
the game
got cancer uh died before they shipped
and what they did was they immortalized
him by putting him in
as a savior character and this would be
someone and it's happened to me multiple
times and every time it just never
maybe it's because i have a different
perspective on it because i got to meet
him and i knew him but
i mean the moment that happens when you
you've been on this you know vendetta
mission or you you've chased down what
has become your nemesis because of the
way that the system operates and you
finally are there and you think you got
him he gets the better of you whatever
and you are staring looking up at him
just waiting for the killing blow and
all of a sudden out of nowhere just
right scream boom he comes in and he was
like you're not dead yet ranger now get
up and fight and he leaves and it's just
like to me in the same spirit of it's i
mean i the first time i've told people
this so many times the first time that
happened to me i literally jumped up in
my room and just bawled i was just like
that's the cool
no matter what role i get in a movie i
will never be able to have
that like that is such a beautiful thing
anyway
so to me in the same way it's like it's
punishing it's punishing it's punishing
it's rewarding but it's punishing
there's i think that game design can go
the other way where it's just like
let's just do nothing but reward you and
to me that's what a lot what journey was
is how do we make a game to where the
only thing you can do for another player
is to help them
i um i i reward games like that it's
again i've i've loved going down this
this rabbit hole of old games and being
able to really think about design in a
different way and think about games in a
different way but every once in a while
there's these
things that snap with me that go is this
good or is this bad if we i use this
analogy a lot with austin
is this a tail or is this a thumb is
this something that we used to have and
we will eventually lose to the process
of evolution or is this something that
is a product of evolution saying this is
actually more beneficial for your
current environment is to have this
thing it'll give you a leg up um
and i don't i'm
constantly the idea of a thumb giving me
a leg up yeah that's a fun fun mix map
for i enjoyed it follow the idioms guys
come on stay with me um
the dude austin you're hosting this
thing and you know it's beautiful
most beautiful for the second time
i got so wrapped up
rahul called
never even rolled audio continuity did
you really not you never rolled over
so there's now two reasons why there may
not be an episode and this is just a
conversation between friends
so let me tell you about what's going to
happen with last of us 3.
never have i i know nothing about that
as a bad joke there's a bad thing i can
confirm you know i i i
never happened oh my god it's not uh
that would be the worst thing is like
troy city's never gonna happen like
troy's refusing to appear in last of us
that's what i thought
um so you may have to hopefully you can
save the audio from this yeah it should
be fine i did you um just my own little
button on that and then i'm pleased
it's your button the um
it's not nearly the same as
that uh shadow of war
shadow of mordor um tribute that is
really that's just
to gamify
someone's tribute in that way and that
everything about that is perfect that is
just
absolutely the best possible i could
only hope that
something i do would be worthy
you know in death of that kind of
tribute that is just so wonderful
the only thing remember most of us are
live right does a special episode of the
podcast right i assume that was the case
that's like when i remember after tim
russert died they did meet the press
where they just held the camera on the
empty chair uh yeah and i remember
thinking that was beautiful
but um the i remember after stan lee
died
um
i
you know
i've always admired him obviously you
know in
in the right company or obviously all
grew up under that influence to varying
degrees
um and and i always loved the fact that
he got to see in his twilight years
you know this career renaissance and
cultural relevance the likes of which he
never imagined even at his prior peaks i
mean yeah immortality and all trump
all those
cameos but i think the one that actually
brought a tear to my eye
was after he had died and i was playing
insomniac spider-man
and you go into the diner with mj and
he's like working behind the counter and
the two leave and he goes you know those
two were always my favorite and i was
like ugh
killed me
so that the shadow of mordor one is even
better because it's actual gameplay
related but those little ways to
bake into games this this recognition
that they're they're they really are
meaningful part of our life and people
that we love and people that we know can
actually figure into them and that to me
that's one of those signs that they are
a form of literature the same way that
all other forms are you know that they
they become a a little marker of where
we are at this point in time and in life
and mass communication as well to take
it back to the communication thing from
earlier like
all three of us have communicated with
more people than we could possibly meet
in our lifetimes true story work we've
done and that's
i that's the thing that like chokes me
up whenever i think about it like you
know he just thomas was alone has been
played by more people than i'll ever
meet
and that the fact that i can reach out
and say something to that many people
even if it's just like hey friendship's
kind of cool isn't it um like that's you
know that matters to me that's something
that's that's that's a
yeah it's incredible and we're all three
of us are lucky enough to be in that
position
we had a we had a thread and we stayed
on it
there it is
mom's gonna be proud yeah she's going to
be so proud when she's watching such a
show
it'll be the best episode we ever did
it'll never air yeah this is going to be
uh this is going to be on the dvd and
the bonus bin i'm going to go watch uh
rudy the rudy julie all these stories go
watch midnight
yeah dude i do need to watch this i will
watch that before we talk next yeah for
sure take us out austin uh all right
well this has been play watch listen and
i'm austin wintry and that's
that's troy baker no wonder this always
gets [ __ ] up you forget my name austin
and that's
mike no it was because you're below i
got you you're the entire bottom of the
screen here you're like holding court
and we're the sort of bodyguards on
either side here that's good i like that
that's right yeah
i think i said it so goodbye
bye
that was a good episode i enjoyed that